he is president Trump's former White
House communications director Anthony
scare emoji the noise
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for you know thank you for
coming I always thank the Republicans
because it is a hard place to come I
always give them I thought like it was
like a Trump fan club meeting and no
it's not and it never is but Republicans
have more balls to come here when they
disagree with me 90% of the time then a
lot of Democrats who agree with me 90%
of the time and they won't come so I
will give the Republicans that they've
got bigger stones oh I wish you could
lend us some her to be here you know Don
and I go back a long time Republicans
and Democrats we we can get along we can
be disagreeable but also try to be
agreeable while we're doing it or be
here's what I would say that some of the
things you said is that okay can I just
please yes so here's the thing I would
say and I would say this both to David
and and also to Donna is that there's a
lot going on I'm not gonna nitpick on
the the memo but when I read the memo
today my reaction to the memo is that
there's something wrong with the spirit
of the situation you know when you're in
law school and I was in law school Rod
Rosen's and he was actually in my
section at Harvard so I've known him for
32 years and I refer and I like him I
mean he's a great guy my section I and I
and I have a lot of respect from I hope
the president does not fire him by the
way because I think he's a very ethical
and I think he's a very decent guy
and so but when I read the stuff and I
know no offense anybody here at the
table but there's something wrong with
the spirit in my mind of what is going
on right now and if the president not
that he would take my advice because I
was only there for 11 days but if the
president it was it could be 954
thousand seconds - by the way if you
look at it that way but but here's what
I would say to you he would be
well-served to put a bipartisan group of
people together and to look at the
processes that we have in place to make
sure that these agencies are shielded
from the accusations of the
politicization honey their son you're
dreaming that's not what he does you
know that better than I do why you even
say that
[Applause]
but I'm I'm saying it for a reason
because I wanted out there in the
airspace I don't want him watching this
that was one of your funniest YouTube
Abul moments yes yet the orange
orangutan and yes not so like that I
mean and does he understand what he's
done to the country that that you know
it's it's it's not New York anymore you
know it called me it's not a building
inspector I know you guys you got the
pin on your thinking yourself there's
papers but time out a second okay there
were two candidates last year that saw
what is really going on in the country
it was it was Bernie Sanders Donald
Trump and people that know me know I
grew up in a middle-class town my
parents didn't go to college you went to
Harvard and I did but that's that's
because but that's because I grew up in
an aspirational working-class family
right the aspirational working-class has
shifted into the desperation of
working-class and I got to tell you self
isn't who Democrats no no I don't really
think it's anybody's specific blame it's
a globalization but more Republicans
okay well more Republicans or more for
the white and given the tax cut you just
gave away to the to the 1% that the tax
cut is actually being downloaded into
wages there's over 300 companies now
that have downloaded the tax cut
you know you know better you know that
where most of the money you know where
most of the money is where is most of
the budget where is the main unfair but
you know
where's most of them I showed up give me
these two minutes to give me the two
minutes give me the two minutes I showed
up when I went to Albuquerque New Mexico
on the campaign and I crossed a secret
service line I took my day pin off and I
went to talk to the people that were
there it was like an epiphany for me
because I was like oh my god he's
talking and messaging to the people I
grew up with if you price my dad's wages
his mid-70s wages 1970 they're down
about 35% in real economic terms you can
blame the Republicans if you want but I
don't really think it's just the
Republicans it's not it's just it's what
happened and would happen in the
globalization focus and so it was one of
the things we're concerned about and you
make some good points what's happened to
the economy but we're concerned about
what has happened to our institutions in
our government so I have a question for
you before you went into government
where you served as communications
advisor you received an enormous offer
from a Chinese group for the purchase of
your company for about 90 million
dollars before you went in after you
came out the purchasers lost interest
that's not true how might understand
that the purchase did not lose a day
that's a factually incorrect statement
do they buy the company they didn't buy
the company because the company needs
cepheus approval and that's an
intergovernmental agency okay this is a
different show but you should call the
Treasury Department you should you're
making an academia and we can't see any
of this so I signed the purchase and
sale
what we're talking about
it's a little bit of like a setup
question he's trying to set they were
bobbing yes for an answer you know I
mean I don't I you know I curse a lot
but I don't curse on TV that's a little
BS actually I'm gonna call you out on
that because you don't know the phone
Kurt I don't course on TV okay first two
reporters you're the one who said the
baton sucks his own [ __ ]
[Applause]
I'm sort of surprised that didn't win
the fake news award okay I'm sort of
surprised about so you didn't say that
no I don't think he's anatomically
capable of it I mean we took it as a
metaphor you didn't say it as a metaphor
I said it I own the right and it's a for
what David's trying to say is that the
Chinese company bought my business we
going back to you okay still stands call
the Treasury asked them why why it's a
national security issue to sell a 200
million dollar I see why you in the set
of course but I see whether you would
Trump get along well New York is if you
actually would get along with them
I hope so because because you got a
tough personality you know how to give
it as well as take it and that's what
its personality but I'll give you this
about Donald Trump he has an almost
inhuman ability to withstand pressure
yeah I've never seen anybody do it like
him never resilient he never moves this
is no really no matter what comes at him
he sleeps well probably like a baby
drooling and matter he never he he
doesn't really sleep that much to be
honest but I know and it's show and it's
show but you know he is the son and he
makes everyone slowly because he's a
ball of gas and dust and he slowly makes
these over a year ago we were saying
like how many these Republicans are
gonna come over slowly or everybody
falls into the orbit of the Sun King and
he does it by just staying exactly right
where he is he doesn't move he's like a
guy at a party some people go to a party
and they circulate some people sit what
let the party come to him he lets
everybody come to him and I would ask
this question I'm not just you but
everybody is he winning cuz he maybe no
I you know I think he's winning but let
me ask you a question why did he win the
election he well Russia helped
[Applause]
we're gonna disagree on that helped not
suggesting that reheat colluded with the
Russians well even if he did he totally
did
but even if he didn't even if he didn't
even if he didn't all seventeen of our
intelligence agency said Russia meddled
in our election that's that's it with
that I accept that and I think that note
that I just said they helps okay but
that's reason why disruption in the
process and I've spent more time in a
Republican administration than you does
a Republican does it does it not does it
not David's coming across not stick in
your craw that Vladimir Putin wanted to
help your guys so much I didn't see you
brought up the WikiLeaks thing the
WikiLeaks guy said doesn't it bother you
don't you ask the question saying why
did my guy tell me where the Russians
know okay I didn't hear you those were
things your level your level of anger
and sanctimony is not coming across
great it's not a performance no no it's
the no one that using
you're turning a deaf ear that card ooh
you're gonna drop Harvard one of the
other
[Applause]
we're with the Harvard how about that
okay I went to LSU alright a good guy
and I have no problem okay I've known
for 32 years
well you mentioned that yeah the
president why hasn't the president
called for an independent commission
away from Congress away from the
partisanship to investigate what happens
and what do we do we just suggested and
I told them it was silly to do it it is
it is part of what rattles the American
oh okay how do we prevent this from
happening right it's happened what are
we going to do he's dead
okay but since we don't have a
waterboarding operation we're not gonna
we're not gonna get him to admit that
point so let's move on that's all right
that's all I'm happy listen um I don't
want objective guy I'm happy to use you
being so cool baby
exactly I'm not want me to quit violets
are blue
I don't want Mouton in my election do
you okay I don't